[Music]
no you're not having deja vu
[Music]
that is in fact olivia rodrigo and
joshua bassett reuniting that's pretty
crazy yep the entertainers who
previously dated hit the red carpet for
the season three premiere of their show
high school musical the musical the
series you can't just zephyr on your way
through auditions this time
i promise you
the best is yet to come
and all seems good for the former pair
[Music]
yeah big smiles silly poses even some
peace signs to the camera it's just
awesome to see people and see their
faces and it's a really special night
but why is this reunion such a big deal
well a lot's gone down between these two
over the past couple of years romance
rumors first started in late 2019 when
their show premiered on disney plus
their chemistry undeniable did my feet
stink
because i feel like my feet snake
oh
sort of yeah i think it's cute
and that's why we work but by july 2020
seemed like they'd split and joshua
joshua's linked to fellow disney star
sabrina carpenter fast forward to
january 2021 and olivia releases a
little song called driver's license yeah
maybe you've heard it before
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
fans speculate the songs about her
breakup with joshua and him allegedly
moving on with sabrina who has blonde
hair and is older than olivia and you're
probably with that blonde girl
who always made me doubt
she's so much older than me she's
everything i'm insecure about and josh
well he shared his side of the story
through music too releasing his track
lie lie lie
[Music]
and get this sabrina also entered the
chat her song skin seemingly addressed
the alleged love triangle
[Music]
but now a year later it seems like water
may finally be under the bridge as all
three stars have achieved big things
olivia won multiple grammy awards
released her documentary driving home to
you and was named billboard's woman of
the year it's incredible i mean writing
songs is just my favorite thing in the
whole world and so to be recognized in
this way is absolutely surreal and i'm
just so grateful to everyone who has
supported me this year and excited for
what's to come joshua is crushing it too
he's released two eps and earlier this
month sabrina dropped her latest single
because i liked a boy which could also
be a nod to last year's drama
[Music]
which brings us back to olivia and
joshua's red carpet reunion marking
season 3 of their hit musical series i
think it was really cool getting being
able to push the envelope not a lot of
shows get to go to season three so we're
very fortunate et spoke with joshua
while promoting the show's latest
installment he teased some big changes
ahead but now we can explore some more
intricate sort of nuances to life um in
theater kids and summer camp and um
there there's so many fun twists and
turns and shooting in l.a was a nice
refresher for all of us i mean i think i
speak for the cast when i say that it
was just it felt like real summer camp
[Music]
you